(audience clapping)
- [Kelly] Have a seat.
Oh my God! You look lovely.
- Oh, thank you.
- Have y'all ever met?
- Have we?
- [Kelly] Look at that
moment? He was like, wait.
- Should we? No, I don't think we've met.
- I know you were an improv person, right?
- Yeah. Yeah.
- So maybe we met back in your
early years. I don't know.
- Either way, it was
memorable for both of you.
- Yes! (laughs)
- I know, obviously. We're like,
- I'll never forget that show.
(Britt laughs)
- You both were like, do you have a story?
Did I not remember that we met?
You both literally had
that panic. It was awesome.
(Man laughs)
We all do it.
Wait, so I think
that you guys do have
something in common though.
So, it is based on these photos.
Let's just take a quick look. Yep.
- [Man] Oh.
- [Britt] Oh. There's, yeah.
- [Man] Oh!
- [Kelly] Yep. Can you explain?
- [Britt] Well, that's
(Man deeply shocked)
That's face paint. Someone
else painting my face.
- But you did that work?
- Oh, yes.
- I mean, yes.
- I did, yeah.
Yeah, my mom and I face painted together.
My mom was a junior high
home economics teacher.
- Oh wow.
- And just insatiably creative person.
And she shadowed a birthday party clown
and learned how to face paint.
And literally no joke.
Two weeks later, she was like
we're starting a small business.
(Man laughs)
And we've got a booth
set up at this fall fair,
that celebrates
everything, apple and pork.
(Man laughs)
And we're turning kids into butterflies,
- Everything, apple, and pork?
- Yeah, it's called the
apple and pork festival.
- I wanna go to that.
- [Kelly] That sounds awesome.
- Where is this?
- Throw in some cider. (Kelly laughs)
- Oh, Yeah. Central Illinois.
You know, they do it.
- Oh.
- Yeah, were turning kids
into butterflies and tigers.
It was this huge success.
So, then we fly
to the international face
and body painting convention.
(Man laughs)
- [Kelly] I didn't even
know that was a thing.
- It's a thing.
- Wait a minute. What year?
Because I was at the
body painting convention.
Maybe we met, then.
(Kelly laughs and claps)
(audience clapping)
- He was, head to toe tiger.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Full on bpdy.
- I can see it. I can see it.
Do you still paint?
- I do. I do.
Well, a couple of years ago
I painted Conan O'Brien's face
as a surrealist, cat giraffe.
And he was really spooky.
- I remember that.
(Kelly laughs)
- You remember?
- A hundred percent, yeah.
Now I it's all clicking.
- It's all clicking. (laughs)
- [Man] Yeah.
- [Britt] That's how we met.
- I love that you both
though have clown history.
Like any, some with clown.
- Were we ever a clown though?
- I was never a clown, but I,
- Please don't call her a
clown. She was a face painter.
- I didn't earned clown.
(Kelly laughs)
You gotta earn clown.
- Oh my God. Oh my God.
It's so different. I was so wrong.
So different. Yeah.
- So, I've been experimenting
since it's COVID time,
I can't paint any faces.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Well, I can't paint your faces.
But I have this new thing I'm
calling face paint from afar.
And I brought one for both of you.
- Oh you did? Oh, wait I wanna see.
- Yes, please.
- Okay. I wanna see, are we gonna see it?
- [Man] Oh!
- [Kelly] I love this!
- [Man] That's me in Paris.
- [Britt] It's you on your own face.
(audience clapping)
- That's actually really rad.
What? I would frame that.
- You can.
- That is so cool.
- And then, we have,
I know you're obsessed with
sunflowers and so am I.
- I am, I want that! (laughs)
(audience clapping)
I want that! (laughs)
- It's yours.
- That is amazing!
Wait did you have a moon as
well? I have a tattoo of a moon.
- [Britt] You do?
- I don't know if you
knew that, but I did. Yes.
- I didn't know that.
- That is amazing what you do.
So you do this with people like online.
Is that what you're,
- I am now? I mean,
this is, I just decided.
- You just started to do business.
- [Kelly] I just decided right now.
- [Britt] I just decided (indistinct)
- Starting a new business, I love it.
Okay, wait.
So your new show is called Severance.
We just had Adam Scott here. Lovely!
- Oh, man.
- It was so great to talk to him.
Who is your character though in this?
- So my character's name is Helly,
and she is who we get the
POV of what it feels like
to get this severance procedure,
where you split your memories
between your work life
and your personal life.
- Because Adam was telling you
that you don't remember your
work life when you're at home.
And you don't remember your like,
as far as the other one, either.
You don't remember when you're
work your home life, right?
- Yeah, exactly.
- It's like, if you were cut into it,
it's the most interesting
thing ever, the concept.
- Yeah.
- Yeah. So who's your
character (indistinct)
- So Helly wakes up on an office table,
having no memory of who
she is or why she's there.
And proceeds to spend the rest the season
trying to escape this office
'coz she immediately knows
there's something off about this place.
- He did not tell me about
your character. What?
- That's fun.
- Wait, is it true that you
can't watch your own show
because you don't have a TV?
- Well,
- [Kelly] I love that you're
an actor and you make movies
and like TV things and you don't own a TV.
- Well, here's the big
scoop. I got a TV this week.
(audience cheering)
- You just now got a TV?
- Has now, got it.
- Are you an avid reader?
I love reading too.
I love TV though as well.
- They're just so big.
Like, well the thing is I did get a,
I went from no TV to huge TV.
- Like a 60.
- It's 65 inch. (Kelly laughs)
- Yeah, makes sense.
- [Britt] It's so big.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Yeah, well we had to
do a virtual premier
for the casting crew, you know recently.
- Oh.
- And I was like, oh, I
don't wanna watch on my iPad.
Like that feels unceremonious. So,
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Got TV.
- You deserve it.
(audience clapping)
- So is there a reason why
you never had a TV before?
- I think just aesthetically.
They're just like this big
box that sits in your house.
So I put it on extension.
- That box is very
entertaining. But, yeah.
- No, it is.
- And they're flat now.
(Kelly laughs)
TV's are flat.
- Mine's a huge box.
- Wait.
- [Man] Hold on.
- I put it on wheels.
So I wheel it to the back room
and then I bring it back out.
- [Kelly] Oh, like on easel.
- [Man] That's great.